[Music]
this morning in our series note to self
we hear from record-setting NASA
astronaut Peggy Whitson
she returned from the International
Space Station back in September after a
288 day mission whitson has spent more
time in space than any other American
Wow while in orbit the 57 year old
biochemist started writing a letter to
her 9 year old self she finished it with
us back home in Houston at NASA Johnson
Space Center for her note to self
[Music]
dear younger me I've learned a few
things over the years that I would like
to share with the younger version of
myself there it is the US for a grand
super to get away you just watched on TV
as Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin took
the first steps on the moon although at
the time it was an unbelievable moment
in history seeing it with your own eyes
made it real and believable and
achievable
[Applause]
[Music]
it made you feel small but filled you
with excitement that moment in time
planted a seed of inspiration in you now
it's up to you to nourish that seed and
grow it into more than just a dreamer
next year your dad will get his private
pilot's license you will get your very
first ride in an airplane
the exhilarating view of the cornfields
from above will inspire you to fly as
well however it will take several years
of raising and selling chickens to earn
enough money to take your own flying
lessons
but just remember learning to fly with
that chicken money will be the first
step toward a higher purpose because one
day you will become a real space
explorer next to Sally Ride the year you
graduate high school NASA will select
the first female astronauts you will
dream of exploration know that what you
dream for might seem impossible but you
will be successful as long as you make
your life decisions based on your own
value system and not others
[Music]
so ignore the naysayers ignore the
people who say you can't become an
astronaut
instead use it as motivation it will be
ten years of applying before ever
becoming an astronaut the rejections
will be discouraging but in your typical
style you will just keep trying all
those years of anticipation will be
surpassed the solid rocket boosters
ignite and you will literally roar into
space and liftoff of the space shuttle
Endeavour
seeing the earth for the first time in
orbit you will be surprised that you
never noticed the quality and texture of
colors.i above earth you will remember
what your parents taught you growing up
on the farm problems don't always have
elegant or expensive solutions dad will
teach you that number two wire and
pliers plus a healthy attitude can fix
almost anything u.s. astronaut Peggy
Whitson returned to Earth today believe
it or not you will spend more time in
space than any other American astronaut
and has now spent more than six hundred
sixty-five days off the planet more than
any other American astronaut and earned
the nickname space ninja
there's our resident space ninja you
will grow soybeans on orbit while your
father will grow soybeans on earth you
will have the opportunity to help build
the engineering marvel that is the
International Space Station she now
becomes the first two-time female
commander of the International Space
Station
you will walk in space 10 times heading
back to the pillar
copy Peggy you will find that living in
space can actually become a home in
spite of tools floating away alien to
all you know you will adapt and you will
love it
know that even though it is
incomprehensible to you you will be a
role model I'm still struggling with
this one so you need to step up a bit
earlier than I have done I would tell
you not to underestimate your abilities
but since I know you I'll just say
challenge yourself you will learn that
you are so much more capable than you
might imagine
or even dream sincerely they old are you
Wow it was so amazing think about all
the accomplishments you make in life and
it really does come down to knowing that
your parents are so proud of you right
saying the only thing it always wells
down that I like how she said challenge
yourself that it started with chicken
money yeah it's not so bad a little sigh
everybody who goes into space somehow
sees have we're a small part of
something much larger yeah that you see
a lot of things up there that you don't
really pay attention to down here but my
big question after watching that piece
what was that green stuff flying through
the air with me I'll be jelly thank you
we'll leave it at jello right it was
della she caught it what an inspiration
she was reached here - you're either an
inspiration to so many women